hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book three of his meditations Marcus
Aurelius is going to introduce a
practice essentially a cognitive
practice that we ought to use as he says
throughout our life in order to be able
to respond to things more rationally
more freely and we're going to see an
example of this besides the examples he
provides there in book six as well in
that famous passage where he talks about
wine being just grape juice and you know
purple robes as being wool died with the
blood or the the Extrusion of a
shellfish and we'll come to that in a
bit but one of the general idea so he
tells us that we should always so the
translation here is Define whatever it
is that we perceive to trace its outline
a little bit more literally we should
always make for ourselves
right so this is poi into to make to
create to do and then it's middle voice
so it's for ourselves a
definition a horror on literally the
boundary of things right so this is a
technical term or an outline hoopo
graphene right graphene is to to write
or to you know put things on a
chalkboard whatever it is going to be
and so hupo around the the thing right
of what makes appearances uh fantas too
um whatever it is that is producing the
appearances that we run into now
Fantasia is a very important technical
term in stoic philosophy it it's
translated as appearances as perceptions
here in Hayes's translation as
Impressions it can also be translated as
imagination because Fantasia is the
faculty of imagination so from the stoic
perspective if we're constantly being
bombarded with appearances of things
right and appearances could be true or
they could be false they could be
illusory they could correspond to what
it is that is there and so Marcus goes
on and he tells us that what we want to
do is see what it really is its
substance
in accordance with the kind of thing
that it really happens to be naked
gumnos sort of stripped down as another
way thinking about there's a word we get
gymnastics from as a whole and
unmodified right so hold on D hollon so
the whole as a whole or the whole
through the hole and the term that he's
gonna use their di remenos right so
we're keeping the thing uh you know
we're dividing it up we're trying to
figure out what it is this is very uh
evocative language here right and then
he goes on and introduces another
consideration so we have you could say
figuring out what's actually there not
being misled by the Fantasia the
appearances
and then using language correctly
calling it by
its proper name onama right
so it's actual name not just the things
that we come up with as euphemisms or as
kind of cliches and the names in plural
of its constituents the things that will
be broken down into and the word used
there is actually a verb of analusis
like the unbinding of things so we're
carrying out an analysis before it's
actually analyzed physically into its
its parts and so he says nothing is so
conducive to spiritual growth no
spiritual growth there is translating a
term
megala Frozen
is is great and then frosunes is coming
from uh you know friends Frances these
things that are connected with our mind
are practical intellect you could say if
you want to and you know of course this
is also suggestive of another very close
term that we often translate magnanimity
or high-mindedness
rights are kind of similar to each other
so nothing is more productive of that he
says as the capacity for logical and
accurate analysis of everything that
happens to us so logical and an accurate
analysis
now alankos and alencane is usually used
for
arguing against something for refuting
something for showing up its weaknesses
it's
failures it's gaps right so it's a kind
of analysis that's a critical analysis
right and uh Toy Lankan Hodo so in
accordance with a hodos a road a path a
method you could say so
um accurate here truthful would be
closer in truth or with truth
of each thing of the the matters that
were being confronted with and so he
says to look at it in such a way that we
understand so here's where we get to all
the different matters the need it
fulfills the the use that it has right
what else
um
in what kind of world and what kind of
arrangement a cosmos its value to the
world as a whole to the entirety of the
world and to human being anthropos in
particular as a citizen of that higher
city of which all other cities are mere
households so the stoics thought of you
know there being a vast Commonwealth a
world city cosmopolites in which we are
all citizens along with the the gods the
other rational beings so that's one
thing that we could think of we could
also ask well what kind of thing is it
what type what what is this thing that
is in front of us right
um what is it made of that's another
question how long was it designed to
last I mean this can save us from a lot
of grief right if we expect things that
are rather ephemeral to last for us for
a very long time and we're probably
setting ourselves up for some
unhappiness very interesting what
qualities it's being translated here
tinos
what kind of virtue what kind of
goodness Pros autograph is needed for
this kind of uh use translated here do I
need to bring to bear on it and he lists
off a bunch of positive qualities
Tranquility courage honesty
trustworthiness straightforwardness
Independence or what what do I need to
do in order to handle this thing well
and then he talks about
um what things are due to or in
accordance with is it the gods who
brought something out uh you know who
produced something who are the causes of
it is it the inter weavings and
intertwinings of where there's you know
this uh some ploke of Fate to
coincidence or chance or this is due to
a human being someone of the same race
the same birth the same Society who
doesn't know what nature requires of him
but I do so I'll treat him so this is
the the virtue I'll treat him with the
law that binds us what the law of nature
requires with kindness and with Justice
this is how we handle things that are
done by human beings if it's done by the
gods or just you know chance or
necessity ah not not a lot of point in
getting pissed off about that right and
getting worked up but if it's due to
human beings we can also say well this
is the kind of thing that human beings
do
and then he says what about
inconsequential things I'll do my best
to treat them as they deserve as
inconsequential things right and so a
very interesting set of observations
there that we can put into practice all
the time and I would argue that what is
going on in book six in this famous
passage chapter 13 is illustrating
one set of examples of this and
interestingly this passage Begins by
talking about
grasping appearances fantasian lambane
right grasping what is in front of a
seizing upon it and then it says uh you
know here's the examples of it roasted
meat in other dishes in front of you and
then realizing to yourself like carrying
out this analysis what is an actual uh
dish well
it's a dead animal he says this is a
dead fish a dead bird a dead pig right
it's a corpse or something and we're
going to eat that up right might be
tasty but you know it's uh
it's just a dead thing why what is wine
why wine or any other liquor is just
fermented stuff from grapes or grain or
milk or whatever it is that you're
fermenting right purple robes now purple
robes were a big deal back in Antiquity
because in order to get the color purple
you had to collect these shellfish and
get the mucus from them and it took a
lot of time and work so purple was a
very expensive color to wear and you
know to have a purple robe this is just
wool dyed with shellfish blood or having
sex some rubbing a brief seizure and a
little cloudy liquid now that's kind of
a funny way to talk about it but you
know if you think about all the stuff
that people do invest in Sex and
attraction and sexuality you know they
say that the biggest organ is the brain
I mean on a physical level there's not a
hell of a lot going on now there is
there we invest it with all of this
importance and all of this
intentionality right so these are
important so he says what we need to do
is latch onto and penetrate into the
substance for all of these appearances
and dxuci right so figure out what kind
of usia what kind of substance the thing
actually is he says we need to do this
all the time all through our lives when
things lay claim to our trust lay them
bare see how valueless they actually are
strip away the legend and interestingly
the word there Historia the story that's
being told about them the narrative the
we could say social investment Right
strip that stuff away the brand name and
we can see things for how they really
are and then we won't be taken in by
them and we will be able to have the
right responses to them and deal with
them in a way that's befitting to a
rational human being